hi there
hello steve kaufman you know you get the
double hello from me because i have to
turn on my other
recording setup for the for the podcast
today i want to talk a little bit about
a man
by the name of daniel tamet
and on my blog i will put a link to an
interview that he has done in german
another one he's done in english
he also has a website he is a savant
in other words he is apparently one of
50 people in the world who have
a certain set of unique
capabilities he is able to calculate
pi you know we all had to
in our maths at school pi was two point
i don't know what it is but he can count
he can remember that down to thousands
of points he can calculate in his mind
he can divide three by 54 and get it
correct down to a 100 or 200 points
behind the decimal i mean he's an
amazing brain
and he can learn a language in a week
and so in this particular interview one
of the interviews with a german
television station
he speaks in german and apparently he
had a teacher there and he just
learned german for a week and he speaks
it
phenomenally
so and he has a language learning system
and so forth
so i thought it'd be interesting to talk
about this issue and and i was so
inspired by it that i went out and i
bought his book which is a bestseller
here embracing the wide sky by daniel
temet and i've read bits and pieces of
it
and it is amazing
i mean it shows us the potential of our
brain
if our brain were wired just a little
bit differently
we would be more like him maybe
and he claims that we can all do much
better than we do in terms of using our
brain and perhaps that's true
but i sort of focused on the things that
he had to say about language learning
and i want to talk a little bit about
them here
the first thing that he said which i
firmly believe is that the brain is a
learning machine it cannot help but
learn and this was a major theme
of manfred spitzer in his book learning
fortune you know brain research and the
school of life
our brains will learn so we got to make
sure that we help them learn and don't
over complicate the teaching
let the brains learn so i certainly
agreed with that and he also makes the
point that once we've learned something
and we learn it and store it in
different parts of the brain that helps
us learn other things if we learn the
word for dog he makes the example you
learn the word for dog or for cat it'll
be easier than to learn
you know the word for another animal the
concept of a four-legged animal now
we're sort of building on the knowledge
that we already have and i think that's
very important i notice it all the time
when you start a new language the more
you know the more things you've managed
to puzzle through the easier it is to
add more things to your knowledge base
if you know nothing everything is
confusing and the brain i believe sort
of picks out those things that are easy
is for you to learn starts to put those
pieces of the puzzle together and then
it becomes easier to learn other things
and it's futile to try to force yourself
to learn
things that are more difficult before
you had some of the other pieces
put together for you
daniel temet also stresses the
importance of emotion
if you can be emotionally involved with
what you're learning about it uh
it's it's very positive it sends you
know positive chemicals charging around
your brain i mean i'm not a scientist
motivation is extremely important
he doesn't talk so much about
attentiveness but it's something that i
believe in it's something that manfred
spitzer mentions
it's something that we've tried to build
into our
learning methodology in other words it's
not just that you have a interesting
content to learn from it's not just that
you're motivated to learn but you also
need to do things to make your brain a
little more attentive now for daniel
tameth that's not an issue because he
just vacuum cleans
all this information and he's able to
get at it and retrieve it
whereas most of us absorb all this
information
and we've listened to hours of this
language we've read it and we can't find
the words they're in our brains
somewhere we can't sort of retrieve them
and i didn't see anything in his book
that suggested that he had
some easy answers as to how we could
improve our ability to retrieve
information we certain that we certainly
have
haven't have absorbed
he has some things that i find difficult
to accept
he sort of says it helps him because
like he he identifies remembers numbers
based on
associating them with color and stuff
like that i can't do that maybe some
people can
and he identifies certain sounds you
know sounds that begin with kr are all
long or short or you know he identifies
the fact that there is a uh
an identification
between what a word sounds like and what
it means and that he claims that can
help us
my feeling is that if that helps us at
all it's happening subconsciously i've
never been consciously aware of
remembering a word because it sounded
like what i thought that you know
meaning should
sound like
uh so i didn't really buy that concept
but for those people who are helped by
it that's fine
he makes the point that a lot of the
difficulty he says and i firmly agree
with this he says that this whole
critical period in terms of language
learning really only applies to the
first language and it doesn't apply to a
second language
and what happens is that the first
language gets kind of locked into your
brain
and it then becomes a filter and it
warps
your attempt to learn other languages so
you tend to pronounce the second
language
in a way that is corrupted by your first
language you tend to use expressions
from your first language so to that
extent having you know perhaps during
your critical period as a child you've
you've fixed on certain patterns
and therefore that influences your
perception of the second language so
that's true
and that's why it's so important to
leave your first language behind
i refer to my first language only in
dictionaries i like to see the new
meaning quickly in my own language
even though i know that that meaning is
very incomplete and that i will get a
better and better sense of the meaning
of that word as i see it in more and
more context but i like that but after
that i don't like to hear english on
audio tape
recordings i want to get away from my
native language i want to get away from
my native culture i want to get
try to project myself and imagine myself
as russian chinese japanese french
whatever language i'm into
the other thing that you know he says he
can learn a language in a week i don't
know how it's possible to do that
uh there are the big thing and here he
agrees you know he makes the point that
which i have always said you know this
whole myth that you if you have a
thousand words you can communicate in a
language
yeah and he demonstrates how in fact
those very common words really don't get
you the meaning in other words all the
meaning is in the 20
less frequent words i you he go that
there then in out from two by whatever
that's not going to get to the meaning
you need a lot of words i'm experiencing
this now in russia i have spent so much
time on russian i have listened to
thousands of hours of russian i've read
lots of russian i have saved
you know 20 000 links in link i am
theoretically i know 45 000 words
and as i read
stuff they're still key words that i
don't understand and my for me the most
the biggest challenge is to get to where
some of these you know the key word that
keeps on showing up that this is the
subject of this article or this point in
the novel
i'm missing it and so there are just a
lot of words i don't know how a person
can even be exposed to all the words he
needs to know in one week let alone
remember them let alone produce them i
can't
this whole business of producing which
is another subject that i should get
into i mean even in terms of getting
things right grammatically uh initially
i couldn't understand the
the grammatical explanations in russian
i now understand them
i now am able to relate them to things
that i'm used to seeing in russian i
even now know that this is the data this
is the janitor this is the instrumental
singular plural feminine mask or
whatever but to produce it
it's still very very difficult doesn't
matter how often i read the explanation
how often i look at the table
and i save them now in link and that's
helping me and i tag them and i review
them but when i go to speak
to try to actually get the instrumental
get that whether it's a ooh or whatever
it might be get the right ending is very
very difficult so unless your daniel
tenet where everything you absorb into
your brain all the input you get is
available to you because you've got this
tremendous control of what's going on in
your brain
uh i don't think one week is is feasible
and i think you're stuck with a longer
process and the key thing is to make it
continually enjoyable and that i must
admit my russian learning remains
tremendously enjoyable i'm very
satisfied with the progress i've made
even though it's taken me almost three
years where daniel tamet does it
in one week so go and see his website